today don't go to college it's the worst
thing you can do and that's going to be
a doctor or an attorney or accountant or
you know some kind of an architect don't
go to college you can do a lot more in
life without going to college I was a
personal trainer that worked at
Disneyland as a fry cook and why as a
bouncer at a gay bar because the gay bar
paid more cuz skinheads would come in to
gay bash and so I needed so much money
that I was willing to get in fights I
was a hundred $26,000 in debt I had
started to businesses and both were
failing they just weren't making it and
I was pretty frustrated and I gotta tell
you I was in a bit of a dark place need
motivation which it took to move
elimination what's that believe nation
it's heaven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack on chewing
today's lessons from a man who went from
escaping communist Armenia growing up
poor and having to eat out of dumpsters
to building several multi-million dollar
businesses and becoming a high
performance coach he's Bejo school Ian
and here's my take on his top ten rules
of success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be a jet fighter so fighter jets
versus crop dusters fighter jets versus
crop dusters is that I believe we all
are raised as fighter jets just we get
neutered by parents by grandparents
because of the filters they had and
viewed life through the experiences they
had teachers who go you don't want to
disappoint yourself just go to college
go get a good job go to college don't go
to college today don't go to college
it's the worst thing you can do and
that's gonna be a doctor or an attorney
and or accountant or you know some kind
of an architect don't go to college you
can do a lot more in life with that
going to college and so again teachers
professors will end up neutering us and
when they take they take that fighter
jet that hunger the claws and fangs they
defend us alright so now we're crop
dusters so I don't want to take too many
risks I just want to live a good life
and they want to be average and mediocre
that's the crop duster yet everyone
inside has this hunger see the fighter
jet didn't go away it's just been
suppressed
you've been neutered and that was me
like hey don't take big gray just go get
a good job go be a smart technician like
that was the advice I was given go be a
smog technician right so I'd be the guy
putting the probe in the tailpipe of
your car and then saying you can go to
your car register Tom that was it that
was it and so I realized very quickly
that I've got this hunger inside me as I
talked to others they got this hunger
inside them ha that's the fighter jet
trying to get out that's the cause and
things trying to grow but the Society
parents whoever have set the standard
for you to not play it safe take risks
what if you lose what have you lose who
care as long as you don't die you can
come right back and so the fighter jet
mentality is that someone who is just
determined relentlessly obsessed in
achieving an outcome in the face of all
adversity the crop duster is someone
who's always looking for the easiest
path the loophole which what I used to
be a severe crop duster the crop duster
hits the snooze button every day because
they'd rather take ten more minutes of
mediocre sleep then getting up and
dominating their path every morning on
my nightstand there's two stacks of
dominoes lined up and at the top of this
stack says you're a loser the top of
this one says you're a winner if I hit
the snooze button I've hit that first
domino on the loser stack the rest of my
day is gonna suck now with that
mentality am I gonna ever hit snooze
again absolutely not because I've sold
myself on the idea that when I hit the
snooze button I'm an absolute loser I'm
scum of the earth I am my day is
destined to be now some people go you're
being awfully hard on yourself
more people should be hard on themselves
we go around bubble wrapping ourselves
right we leave the training bills on for
too long like be hard on yourself take
the bubble wrap off take the take the
training wheels off no one did that for
me man we came to this country and it
was just like hey go figure it out but
it was don't take risks to go get a good
job that'd be a fighter jet be a fighter
jet go to battle every day take risks
that's what a fighter jet does a crop
duster has a routine life and it's
boring
rule number two improve your sleep
pattern I've had the best coach over the
last seven years that I've known him and
that's Greg Valentine what do you thinks
the biggest lesson you learned from him
in the last seven eight years the
biggest lesson was to sleep at the same
time wake up at the same time seven days
a week no matter what really his sleep
is so valuable it's so important so I
rated I used to think that I here's what
I was I'm a fighter jet I would
literally walk around the house honey
I'm a fighter jet fighter jet you know
doesn't even come down to get refueled
they're up there getting revealed right
right we've all seen the YouTube videos
yeah well the fighter jet if they leave
those afterburners on too long they just
fall out of the sky which I know one had
told me right until I fell out of the
sky I was having essential tremors and
anxiety attacks and not realizing it and
as I got better at sleep those just went
away cuz the one discipline leads to
another and to another how you do
anything is how you do everything right
and so that that one thing that he
taught me or I learned through him and
we'd be in Vegas we'd run a mastermind
together because now we run a mastermind
together and eight o'clock he's gone
buddy where you going to sleep yeah I'm
gonna by nine or whatever better yeah
yeah exactly he powers off thirty
minutes all his electronics before so
now I do the same thing I power off I
don't go to bed and then do this yeah
powered off thirty minutes before and my
mind stops racing and the left and right
side start reconciling of the
information I took in throughout the day
versus the information I keep consuming
taking right until I fall asleep and
then over
knows what happens in my brain wherever
I write what time to go to bed and wake
up 10:30 10:30 I'm in bed wake up at
5:30 Wow and and that's its parallel no
matter what even if you're in Vegas or
I'm traveling around the world or
whatever
yeah I'll adjust that timezone real
quickly and 10:30 I'm in bed 5:30 a.m. I
wake up when I go right through my
rituals rule number three solve a
problem when you're driving down the
highway and you see a coca-cola
billboard and then you see a big giant
bus in the city with the coca-cola
advertisement on it do you think
coca-cola knows where the sales are
coming from are they able to track the
sales from the billboards or the sales
from the bus or the sales from the movie
theater obviously not right they do
branding as advertising and they have a
ton of money and so they are just
shooting their brand out everywhere and
they are everywhere all the time right
omnipresence now when I first started
out with Fit Body Boot Camp and I wanted
to make this a global brand I didn't
think about how I can brand myself I
just wanted to do one thing I wanted to
sell one franchise location and when I
sold one franchise location I said I'm
gonna sell another franchise location
and then I sold a third franchise
location and a fourth and a fifth and
now we have hundreds of Fit Body Boot
Camp locations worldwide we've created a
national brand and it's become a thing
but before you can make yourself a thing
before you can make your business a
thing you got to first just focus on
direct response marketing direct
response marketing is accountable
marketing I know that it feeds the ego
to see yourself as a brand and a public
figure and but listen if you were to
just start putting your logo or your
brand all over the place
how are you gonna be able to track where
the money's coming from you're not gonna
be able to track that and if you can't
track it you can't quantify it the best
branding you can do in your business is
to make a promise and to keep a promise
when I created Fit Body Boot Camp
International my goal was to take
personal training and reduce the cost of
personal training I wanted people who
couldn't afford personal training to
work with a personal trainer at a
reduced rate so we went from one-on-one
personal training to the bootcamp style
and the whole idea there is one
coach or trainer and many clients and
that reduces the cost that each
individual person is paying I knew that
there was a problem and so I brought in
a solution whatever brand or whatever
business or idea that you have right now
I don't want you to think about branding
I want you to think about solving a
problem you go and you solve the problem
and everything else will fix itself
because you'll sell one and then two and
three and so whether you're building a
franchise or you're building a media
marketing agency or maybe you're just a
one-off location selling cupcakes make
the best cupcakes you can on the planet
and when you do guess what happens
people talk about you rule number four
break the limiting beliefs so when we
came to America we were poor and broke
the way I look at it because we would
always run out of money before run out a
month we decided you know do we do
without electricity or or gas because
some months we couldn't afford to pay
both and you know being broke as being
without money being poor as being kind
of scarcity minded poor minded and we
just realized that money's for the rich
money's for the the Americans it's for
the people who were born here who went
to college and that's how I grew up and
later Jim Franco taught me that hey you
know what you can't be scarcity minded
you can't you have to live in abundance
you have to understand that people just
want a solution to a problem and they
don't care about the color of your skin
about the level of your education they
want a solution to prompt so he taught
me he had to break all these old
patterns that I had right what were some
of the patterns some of the patterns
were that money's for the white folk and
not for the foreigners you actually
thought yeah hey I'd really cuz that's
that's how it was because every time we
went and got got more food stamps it was
all foreigners there's no white people
in line at least not not in the parts of
Santa Ana that I was raised and so I
felt that money was for the people who
were telling us to leave this country go
back to your own country and that also
puts a chip on your shoulder right
against them and so I guess I had some
reverse racism towards towards white
America now I realize for no apparent
reason there was a couple of idiots and
never
culture I imagine right but so that was
one pattern that I had another pattern
that I had was that being proud to be
blue-collar like my dad was like and he
still says this work is holy and I
believe that work is holy but the fact
that he had so many jobs a paper route
pumping gas worked at a pizzeria and so
because of that mindset blue collar blue
collar we were always a blue collar
mentality and I took pride in being blue
collar another pattern Jim Franco had to
have the break was I think dude
be white collar don't use the shovel
sell the shovel I'd never heard that
phrase before I'm the guy that took
pride in I could dig a deeper hole a
deeper trench I could I could outwork
you but that's still trading time for
dollars and so to be able to break those
who limiting belief systems that I had
to me was huge and all of a sudden I
realized I'm no longer poor minded I may
end up broke again I do really well now
but I may make one or two bad decisions
with my money or my investment to end up
being broke again but I'll never be poor
and I know how to get back from broke
because I know how to add value to
society solve problems and exchange for
money but I'll never be poor again and
poor is a state of mind of feeling out
of control
scarcity minded taking pride in being
blue-collar no one should ever take
pride in being blue-collar period period
you've got a brain you've got a solution
to a problem that people want to pay for
put it out there so when you say
scarcity minded abundant minded what do
you mean
well the scarcity minded person says Oh
someone else opened up a gym you know
across the street for me they're gonna
put me out of business I better charge
less right the abundant minded person
says someone else opened up the gym
across the street from me I better out
service them out work them out social
media them right so the scarcity minded
person is always the sky is falling the
Chicken Little mentality the omigosh of
Trump goes into office then we're all
screwed oh my gosh if Hillary goes into
office then we're all screwed I don't
care who's in office anymore I control
my own economy the economy can crash and
go back up and back down again I will
find a way as Tony Robbins says I'm
built for winter I just didn't know it
and so more people need to be abundant
minded in that with the economy crashes
I just have to deliver more value
and create this category of one about
myself if competition shows up I have to
out service them out work them out
social media them versus shrivel up and
die rule number five find mentors when
and if and when you go to find a coach
make sure that they practice and not
just profess mmm not right right right
they're doing they've been there so I
was a personal trainer that worked at
Disneyland as a fry cook and why as a
bouncer at the gay bar because the gay
bar paid more to skinheads would come in
to gay bash and so I needed so much
money I was willing to get in fights I'm
not a fighter I can talk my way out of
any fight big dude though it's it's
God's gift of intimidation yeah the the
talking doesn't work I can her and then
I run right and so I'm that trainer who
then was able to open up five gyms make
them successful finally because until
then I was a personal trainer fry cook
and a bouncer a client took mercy on me
and said hey man you're not a closer
you're an order-taker or listen to this
Tom Hopkins tape you didn't close me you
just took my order and that hurt right I
said well you're right I have two two
side jobs people who come to me give me
objections I don't know how to handle
the spousal objection money objection
time objection so I let him walk so I
just take the people who are like how
much is personal training I want to buy
ten sessions great let me take your
order right and so as my mentor Jim
Franco you know gave me that tape and
Tom Hopkins leads to Brian Tracy Brian
Tracy to Dan Kennedy Dan Kennedy Halbert
etc and you know and then I start
learning personal development right you
know the Tony Robbins and and and and
all of a sudden my mind is opened up
into my surroundings of the people
around me who do I need to cut out
because they're cancerous versus who I
need to spend more time with because I
need a rise to their level and all of a
sudden I realize holy cow and these got
built-in coaches as a personal trainer
one-on-one your clients are typically
the affluent people right right so I
started asking all my my clients in
between workouts right you know a little
business advice here a little business
advice there and I found that these are
people who practice one guy's got a
software company next guy this
automotive company right
rental cars public storage places
and man who was just the best advice
versus taking advice from a family
member or friend who goes I heard it on
shark cam he's not practicing who
doesn't experienced it yeah so that's
the big thing is to take advice from
someone who's been there and done that
and and if they they're consulting in
your industry but they come from a
different industry I would tread
cautiously yeah okay yeah but you think
everyone should have a coach I believe
so I think so too
as athletes we have coaches all right I
try to do it on your own no no if you've
dealt with trauma in your life whether
it's some kind of physical abuse sexual
abuse whatever neglect as the kid you go
to a therapist a good therapist is a
coach yes right you've got personal
development coaches like the Tony
Robbins like the random bouchard's why
not have business coaches why not have
high performance coaches if you've got
limiting beliefs why not have someone
reset your thermostat that mom and dad
had set so low Yeah right or
circumstance of growing up it said solo
we're in it we can't see the trees yeah
I look at it as a coach a good coach is
in a helicopter saying you know you see
a lot of trees but I know if you go up
50 yards that way and then 10 yards that
way you've got an open path be open up
yeah that's it that's what a coach does
he buy you time they buy you speed that
buy you success rule number six serve
someone asked me what's the number one
lesson I would like to give to myself if
I can go back 20 years in time right and
that lesson would be the lesson that I
already share with my kids right now
see I'm raising kids right now who are
gonna be entrepreneurs they're gonna be
change makers they're gonna be a useful
part of society and and I'm guessing
that if you're following me if you watch
my stuff that you subscribe to my
channel if you if you want anything to
do with me then you care about impact
you care about meaning you want to build
an empire that leaves a legacy behind
them
happen listen up young entrepreneurs for
that to happen you're going to have to
wake up every morning and pick between
one of two shirts now the shirt that I
used to pick to wear every morning said
what can you do for me see I was a
pretty selfish guy I was the type of guy
that always looked to you and you and
you and try to figure out what can you
do for me I'm gonna get something for
you how can I find the loophole
where's the value in it for me these
days I wake up on the ground that shirt
and says how can I help you see the more
people you can help the most people you
can serve the more you'll get what you
want sig Ziegler said it best years ago
when he said the more you can help
others get what they want
then you'll get what you want right and
so every morning when you wake up you
have one of two shirts to wear you can
either be selfish and wear the shirt
that says what can you do for me or you
can be a giver a servant leader that
says how can I serve you and the more
people that you serve the better your
life will be I promise you and course
the bigger the Empire you'll bake
building and the more impact
you'll make best of all you'll have
peace of mind knowing that you're
helping out humanity which at the end of
the day we're all here on this planet to
have some sense of meaning right so wear
that shirt how can I help you rule
number seven build toughness 2010 you
know I kind of called myself I'm a
meathead I just lift weights and put him
down right I had kind of painted myself
into that corner why not go run a
marathon so I trained for six weeks and
went and ran a marathon it was the most
painful thing I ever did but I realized
that was more the suffering and the pain
and the more pain I had the more put me
into the zone of wanting to dominate so
it is a superpower so I must now go back
and put myself into these challenges Rob
claiming I was afraid of heights took on
a six-week challenge started climbing
Rob's wanted to fight a professional MMA
fighter so I hired him trained for six
weeks one of the Ring and got my ass
kicked and choked out but each time I
did that it gave me the sense of I can
get over any obstacle and if I can get
over getting choked out and punched and
the pain of 26.2 miles in a marathon or
overcoming my fear of heights surely I
can build a business surely I can take
some criticism online right but not
enough people are willing to build that
mental emotional
toughness and the moment they do though
persevere rule number eight my personal
favorite believe you're from Armenia
right I am like ya might move yeah my
dad was a member of the Communist Party
and in 1981 my brother was to go into
the Red Army at at the time of course
they're fighting Afghanistan right
Russia and so in 1980 we escaped Armenia
which at the time was under communist
rule Russian rule went into Italy and my
dad demands that I say this next part we
legally entered into the United States
from Italy into New York which is a very
big thing Wow
and so he worked his ass off and I
learned English and we amazing yeah we
have weighed out of dumpsters right it
was a typical rags to riches story but I
was the six-year-old kid who I thought
it was fun crawling into dumpsters you
know it's an adventure for you yeah yeah
little did I know that I hey get that
lettuce take it that jug of milk you got
it here we go I'm having a good time and
so it was a neat experience and um
that's a hey we're in a free country now
you can be anything you want and I was I
was uh I was stubborn enough to believe
that I could become anything I wanted
here Wow rule number nine Maine in 2014
I realized because 2014 I was having
literally a major anxiety attack once a
week and if it wasn't an anxiety attack
it was an essential tremor where my body
would freeze up and I would just start
shaking and my wife would what's going
on with you and I couldn't talk and I
would shake and my teeth would chatter
for two to three minutes at a time and I
had to go get neurologically tested and
we realized that it was just the stress
and anxiety manifesting in a different
way instead of a panic attack it was
essential tremors so in 2014 I told
myself it's time to man up it's time to
man up and say what do I want to do with
this business Fit Body Boot Camp up into
that point I treated it as a hobby and I
it's embarrassing to say this man but if
I'm gonna be fully transparent I treated
Fit Body Boot Camp and my coaching
business as a lifestyle hobby if I made
enough money to travel and have a little
bit of freedom and buy a sports car that
I want I'm good and I knew there was
something missing but I kept burying my
head into it what was missing is I knew
I had greater potential and I had a
bigger purpose on this planet to touch
more lives but I was being lazy on
and poorly discipline and that was
giving me anxiety attacks and essential
tremors in the end of 2014 I said it's
time to man up and I said I need 2,500
fit body boot camp locations I want to
have thousands of coaching clients I
want to help 100 million people
worldwide that's my personal goal and
it's no different than Gary Vaynerchuk
saying I want to buy the New York Jets
like that's a definitive goal and he
will work as hard as he can to have the
money to buy it whether he buys it or
not doesn't matter this is what trips me
out is when people leave comments on his
Facebook wall or wherever they go hey so
what are you gonna buy the Jets his goal
is to have enough money to buy it
whether he buys them or not doesn't
matter once I get to a hundred million
people's lives impacted for date through
my coaching clients and Fit Body Boot
Camp locations I'll decide if that's
enough or not but right now that's a
very big carrot in front of me and I
have something to focus on in 2014 I
didn't have that if you came to me in
2014 and said Kratos let's start a
underwater basket-weaving franchise
great let's do that and some other guy
came to me and said let's start an info
product selling this great let's do that
I was a hobby a promotion guy now I'm
highly focused on my coaching clients
and my franchise and nothing else and
rule number 10 the last time before a
very special bonus clip is remove the
crabs from your life you know it's funny
being here on the banks of the
Mississippi River it kind of reminds me
of a story that took place in Ketchikan
Alaska and the only way I ended up in
Ketchikan Alaska was because my wife's
grandparents in 2005 decided they're
gonna take the whole family on a cruise
and listen I was a hundred $26,000 in
debt I had started to businesses and
both were failing they just weren't
making it and I was pretty frustrated
and I gotta tell you I was in a bit of a
dark place and I could not have afforded
a cruise to Alaska but thankfully my
wife's family paid
and we ended up there we're newlyweds
right broke and we're walking on the Sun
on the shore they're in Ketchikan Alaska
and I see all these like crab fishermen
they're testing out a net and then
they'll pull the net in and they'll pull
out a crab or two and throw it in a
five-gallon bucket so as we're walking
along I see this one guy older gentleman
he's got a five-gallon bucket
he's got a little bit of water in there
and he's got the lid to the bucket
sitting on the ground and he's casting
his net in the water he waits for a
while and he pulls out some crabs and it
puts him in the bucket when I look
inside I see about five or six crabs all
just kind of piled up and there was this
one crab that seemed pretty ambitious to
me and this little guy was crawling on
top of all the other crabs real slowly
and then when he got to the very top he
started reaching up for the rim of that
bucket and pulling itself up now when I
saw this of course something oh my gosh
I got to tell this crab fisherman that
his crab is about to make a break for it
and probably run right back into the
ocean and so I go hey sir you're about
to lose one of your crabs you might want
to do something put a lid on it because
watch what happens next and as this
little ambitious crab is trying to free
itself and and pull itself up and over
the rim of the bucket all the other
crabs in the bottom reach up grab it by
its hind legs and pull it right down
right now in that moment my wife is
standing right there next to me and I'm
a hit there I'm saying can you believe
what's happening here can you see what
just happened
we all have crabs like that in our lives
right we all have people that want to
pull us down we all have negative people
doubters haters people who criticize us
people who don't think we'll make it
because you're not smart enough you
didn't go to school for that you don't
have the money to afford that you don't
have the resources you don't have the
experience you've got to be like that
little ambitious crab shake off the
haters and the criticizers and the
doubters and surround yourself with
badasses who are rooting for you and
want to see you succeed
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Bay Joe's on how to explore your
purpose but before that I want to know
what did you learn from this video what
message hit you the hardest what are you
going to apply immediately somehow to
your life your business put down the
comments when you write it down you're
much more likely to actually follow
through on it so leave it in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
man I don't think that we would be here
if we didn't have a purpose I can tell
you that I truly a purpose that's given
to us or no no it's our job to develop
that purpose it's our job to find and
hone in and craft that purpose and that
purpose is usually crafted through some
level of suffering it's the hero's
journey right like in film you know the
hero he's down and out and then he loses
the girl in the in the house and he goes
on this journey and he finds strength
and wisdom and knowledge and comes back
and is now the hero we have to go
through that level of suffering like for
me everything that happened from being
molested to literally one day eating
caviar for breakfast because my dad was
a member of the Communist Party the next
day
starving in Italy and wondering why are
we sharing one banana for a family of
five what is going on and and so there's
this hunger that everyone has and it's
always neutered by a family my teachers
by culture and I believe you wouldn't be
put on this planet if you didn't have
this hunger and if you explore this
hunger and for me it was then being a
fat kid than being a being a foreigner
then a fat kid and then fixing my
problems and then realizing I have the
solution to other peoples weight-loss
problems for someone else it might be a
financial thing you know they fix their
financial problems and they realize they
can help everyone else's financial
problems but you have to go through the
suffering you have to be hungry enough
to deal with the pain and come out the
other side with some scars because scar
tissue is infinitely more resilient than
regular tissue but again goes back to
most people feel like yeah I think
there's something great in me but I
don't want to explore it I want to play
it safe I'm gonna stay bubble-wrapped
I don't want to risk it but we wouldn't
be put on this planet if we didn't have
this greater thing to accomplish now
some of us are going to be Elon Musk and
we're gonna shoot a Tesla to the Mars
right and that's okay and others are
going to create a fitness franchise or a
or a supplement company that actually
delivers you know great nutrients that
help people in my their performance some
other people are just going to be real
great therapist they're gonna keep
throughout their life maybe you save 10
12 15 people from killing themselves
whatever your purpose is you've got to
develop it you got to develop it but you
wouldn't be put on this planet if you
didn't have it I'm convinced of that if
you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it don't you
believe you act like I am Tulsa what a
wail out of a handcuffed lightning
though Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between 18 and 250 4 days of taking
action for a new habit to stick I've
created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250 4
days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access